for the last three weeks the litigation
against deshaun watson has largely
played out peter in the court of public
opinion it goes to a court of law
today and rusty harden who represents
watson has been telegraphing this
for weeks now the idea that there will
be some sort of a
challenge to these 22 lawsuits based
upon the fact
that 20 of them continue to proceed with
the jane doe
pseudonym emergency hearing today aimed
at
forcing the 20 who have not attached
their names
to their lawsuits to do so now
there are other ways to raise that issue
those other ways would take more time i
firmly believe that harden
has embarked on this strategy to try to
get tony busby who represents all 22 of
the individuals to come to the table
and try to get all cases resolved sooner
rather than later so deshaun watson can
be traded
can have some certainty can clear this
problem off of his docket and
and i i need to say this anytime i
mention the possibility of settlement
i'm not saying make it go away quickly
and easily i'm saying finding a way
to take your reckoning to make things
right but i think there's
value in making it happen sooner than
later if watson is ready to do that
but at the same time i think they're
having a hard time getting tony busby to
the table
this what's happening in court today i
believe is a device
to force busby to the table to the
extent that any of these 20 women just
say we don't want our names to come out
under any circumstances
here's the issue that i see now mike is
you know
it's it's it's it's april
and as i try to figure out and i try to
think about
you know the what will happen
by september you would know a lot better
than i would
but the one thing i keep thinking is
look at all of and again i don't mean to
just transition to football
immediately okay but
as we proceed through the off-season
look at how many doors are being closed
on uh the texans general manager nick
casario
and on desean watson look at all the
teams
that have already solved their their
quarterback dilemma
let's say for the year okay and now
look at what might be available if
houston
if say all of this is solved maybe if he
gets some sort of suspension from the
nfl
but if at some point in 2021 he's able
to play football
i mean where's he gonna go what owner
wants to take on the onus of
desean watson in this me too society
so i think there's still a lot of
questions that regardless of
what happens to him legally in the next
three or four months
what will happen to deshaun watson
in a gridiron sense in 2021
is a gigantic mystery but you know the
tampa buccaneers brought in antonio
brown even though there's a pending
lawsuit against him in florida for
sexual assault and rape now it's one
victim not
22 and i think the sheer magnitude
changes things for desean watson
at least two of the individuals who have
sued him have spoken to police and there
is a possibility
of criminal charges being filed but
if he can find a way and again to do it
the right way to properly have his
reckoning to properly compensate
and make these individuals believe that
they've had their day in court that
they've had
some form of justice that is acceptable
to them under the circumstances
especially if
20 of them can avoid attaching their
names to these lawsuits
as part of this process to the extent
that that could be done
sooner than later and that they agree as
part of it that it's over that it's
finished that they're not going to talk
about it publicly as a practical matter
they wouldn't be able to cooperate with
the nfl
because the nfl has no subpoena power
over these individuals
once they've agreed not to talk about it
to anyone which is a legitimate way of
resolving
situations like this that is what lays
the foundation
for deshaun watson to to get this behind
him in 2021 whatever that means by way
of an nfl suspension and we don't know
what the nfl will do peter ben
rothersberger was suspended six games
reduced to four in 2010
with two incidents one of which resulted
in a lawsuit
the other resulted in nothing now i
still believe that there was some sort
of a resolution
that was made between roethlisberger and
the alleged victim but there was no
prosecution there was no lawsuit
arising from the incident in
millageville georgia two incidents
and ben roethlisberger was suspended
ultimately four games 22 incidents now
plus this pattern of behavior that
suggests that
something's not right the nfl could
easily suspend him multiple games could
suspend him justifiably for the full
season
by the time it's all said and done but
you don't even get to the point where
the nfl is taking up
what to do until these cases are
resolved you could otherwise have a
situation where
one or two seasons are lost to the
commissioner exempt list
and then after that the nfl passes
its judgment so there is value
in getting these cases resolved now i
believe i don't know
but i believe watson would like to do it
and i think tony busby as he represents
his clients understands
that there's value in being coy there's
value in being unpredictable
because that could drive the price up
and that's how you measure justice in
the civil justice system how much one
side pays to the other
and i think today's hearing is aimed at
forcing busby to the table
because they would like to get this
cleared away from a legal standpoint
as soon as possible and maybe before the
draft and maybe there is a team out
there
maybe there is if all these cases would
be over and
resolved to the satisfaction of the 22
women involved and it's done
and that's it maybe there is a team that
would
make that trade knowing there's a strong
possibility there'll be a suspension to
be served in 2021 peter
and that and then you ask the question
okay could it be a team
that already has made strides
with another quarterback could it be the
carolina panthers
and could they and i don't know whether
they have told sam darnold directly
that we're exercising your your option
for
uh 2022 i i don't know whether they have
or not it seems like
they will but what would happen if
desean watson suddenly became available
would the panthers then basically kind
of say hey sorry
uh sam darnold that's the cost to do in
business you know would the miami
dolphins get involved
i i don't think so but who knows
so there's all of these questions that
that
we don't really know until we have some
idea
of what desean watson's status is
for 2021 and we're not going to know
that until
you know the legal wrangling plays out
one last quick point and we made this
earlier in the week and i just want to
re-emphasize it here to the extent that
deshaun watson continues to follow
a strategy that entails hunkering down
and fighting
that is the thing that could keep him
out of football for multiple years and
potentially derail his career entirely
if he's ready to understand that
something happened that shouldn't have
happened he needs to find a way to make
it right
he puts it behind him that's when he
sets himself up for his redemption
that's what mike vick did mike vick
finally abandoned the fight
in 2007 served his time came back to the
nfl but you have to have that moment
where you pivot away from fight fight
fight fight fight deny deny deny deny
deny
and accept the fact that you have to
acknowledge that something happened you
need to make it right that's how you lay
the foundation
for your return to the nfl whenever that
may be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports